Monisha is the the CEO and founder of
Poshmark and he's gonna tell us a story
of a how he scaled this company and and
made it happen so let's give a round of
applause for Manish good afternoon I
feel like last time I was here I was
watching TV corporation so I'm feeling a
little bit of a rock star here so I
might start dancing or something here
well I'm gonna tell you a little bit
about how we created Poshmark which has
grown to be a very avid sort of social
fashion marketplace platform and really
where we focused on a cold tenant which
is love and really build the entire
platform and how love operates as a core
tenet of communicating and tying a lot
of emotions
and one of the central founding
principles of the company and the
platform is that when you focus on love
money comes and when you focus on money
nothing comes and that sort of how we've
grown this thing how do I is it a
clicker here there is okay so the the
key thing that really what the
opportunity we saw was that there were a
lot of marketplaces that were geared
towards selling products but there was
nothing that enabled any individual to
really participate in the world of
fashion and style and my incise from
creating caboodle was that a lot of
fashion discovery had to be done through
people and if you look at sort of the
last five years and see the migration of
how fashion has moved more and more
online a lot of it is driven by
individuals and people influencing how
fashion is consumed and discovered
online and by fashion I we really take
it in a broad way we certainly talk
about the clothes and items we wear but
then we also talked a lot about anything
that is style and discovery based
products and that is sort of some of the
future of there we can really expand the
platform and bring a whole bunch of
products that people can buy and sell in
Poshmark the the key thing we wanted to
do from day one
was to build a community and to do that
we really started with literally one
person at a time so for the first year
of existence of the company at the end
of that year we had 800 total users and
those 800 users were recruited literally
one person at a time a lot of them
actually not far from here in in in a
bar in so mine in city called district
where we would really bring the
community into the in into that where my
team would go out and recruit and we
teach them how to take pictures how to
sort of photograph and how to sell items
and in fact in the early days we didn't
have any payment or shipping system so
we really focused on using that place as
also as a venue for transacting so
people would bring little packages of
clothing and transcend them like little
secret drug deals that were going on in
the bar and that's how sort of we
started the the platform and one of the
the big realization that we had was that
people were craving to be connected in
real time and people were craving to be
connected with each other in sort of
this virtual world that was emerging
around mobile computing in 2010 2011
timeframe so what we created and have
sort of started to enable is what we
call the next generation of retailers so
these are people who are starting
fashion businesses and and scaling
fashion businesses where they may start
with just stuff in their closet but then
slowly build out a fashion boutique
which has may be generating hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year and in the
last year we've also enabled them to
turn them into fashion brands that
they're creating hundreds of boutiques
that are selling on their behalf so what
you see is a person like suzanne cannon
who's a mother who has two kids who
lives in texas who started out by
selling from her closet built out a
business over the last two or three
years that is a boutique launched her
own fashion brand called infinity rain
on Poshmark
and now has over 250 other women on the
platform selling on behalf of suzanne
cannon and building out a boutique
network for infinity rain so it's really
changing that sort of whole process
we've raised little over seven million
dollars we have close to a little over
two and a half million seller stylists
and what's remarkable today is that
in Poshmark pricing which is actually
many times discounted from retail
pricing these women are uploading and
now men are uploading little over 4
million dollars of inventory a day which
is roughly a way to think about it is
that every 3 or 4 days people are
opening up what is the equivalent of a
Nordstrom store and Poshmark the the
cool market opportunity is massive we
are talking about 30 trillion that may
be a little overstated but but they are
really spending a massive amount of
money I think the the stat is a little
about a trillion dollars worth of our
fashion is consumed every day every year
and so every three years it's like close
to three trillion dollars I think that
may be the number that they've wanted to
put here and a lot of it just sits in
the closet and goes to waste so we've
really found a place and a way for that
to sort of get consumed but more
importantly by connecting people to
people what we are doing is bringing
back small retail in an online setting
so if you go back 30 to 40 years in
America the way V bought products was we
would walk into a neighborhood store
whether it was for fashion or Hardware
and was Tom or Jenny they would know you
by name they would in fact merchandise
to that store cater to his towards
specific customers and they would when
you walk in and they say hey this is not
just the screw that you want today but
the here's a hammer there's not just a
dress you want but there's a piece of
necklace to go with it well over time as
we move towards big-box retail
that personal touch disappeared and
everything became sort of SKUs and items
and products when we moved to ecommerce
we sort of just took that same model and
fly to e-commerce and things became even
bigger and more massive and then we
tried to bring personalization
as a substitute for personal well
personalization could be Minority Report
but it isn't personal what we are really
doing is enabling Jenni to know you by
name and that's exactly what happens
that's why our seller stylists have a 75
to 80 percent repeat selling process and
we did that by really creating a social
framework
when you build your follower network you
start to get that repeat selling
paradigm happening but the second thing
that happens is what used to happen
again in the olden days where it wasn't
just the brand it was also the
communication that you were putting
around the brand that led to the
consumption by the person by building
that affinity with the seller stylist it
allows many different independent and
smaller brands to actually thrive on the
platform in fact when you look at our
wholesale engine the top five brands
advance you've never heard of and these
guys have scaled from zero to millions
of dollars of revenue in just less than
a year on Bosch mark as a platform this
is our first first team and one of the
key to creating a great company from day
one is to really recruit the right team
and I've been privileged to not only be
surrounded by an amazing team but the
fact is that almost all of these people
are still here today six years later and
through a lot of ups and downs we are a
company that really prides on really
bringing people together and then
keeping them whether it is our team or
it's our community if you look at
cohorts which is a group of people who
join at a certain point in time and
scale up our cohorts deliver revenues as
if it is sort of you know if they
generate a million dollars in the first
year they keep generating a million
dollars forever and in fact grow on top
of that and that is something you don't
see that kind of loyalty across the
whole whole platform so when we sort of
really started one of the key things we
wanted to do was to keep not just
shopping which is you know has to be
simple and fun but also selling simple
and fun and to do that we had to fight
many different battles so one of the
things sort of vision I had was if
you're an eighteen year old girl and
you're sitting in a college dorm and you
want to sell or shop on Poshmark it
shouldn't be a chore it shouldn't
require you to sort of or on ramp as a
merchant figure out how much things
weigh figure it out you know to build a
reputation online etc etc it should feel
like fun selling and buying should feel
like taking Instagram photos or taking a
selfie on a snapchat and being able to
participate in it to do that we had to
fight a lot of sort of built in
logistics payment systems that existed
out there we challenged the norm of how
payments and
distribution of payment should work and
that led to in 2013 two years after we
started the company and things were
scaling well every single payment
processor in the country had rejected us
and we were almost two months from
shutting down because of the mindset we
took to the problem saying that we will
only want to support a payment
processing system that eliminates the
need for every one of our seller
stylists to onboard as a merchant and it
took many more months to fight many
different battles before we won that
thing so today when you come in you can
literally take a few pictures and go out
and start to sell and you don't have to
on board as a merchant no matter what
your scale is you could be still doing
millions of dollars of business or
selling one item and that allows a very
seamless experience to happen where
today in just the hour that you'll be
sitting here over three to four hundred
people would have opened up and signed
on as new seller stylist on the platform
second thing we had to do was to make
shipping simple fashion as this unique
characteristic where most items are very
very light however items can have very
random shapes and sizes and at the same
time some things can be arbitrarily
heavy what that leads to is is that you
really don't know how much it's gonna
cost to ship something you don't know
what it'll take to do that the second
characteristic is particularly for
women's fashion that exists is even
though it can take weeks to make a
decision once a person makes the
decision they want it tomorrow so it is
quite possible that I now need that
dress to wear on a date tomorrow or for
a wedding this weekend how do you make
that happen so you need speed efficiency
flexibility and all of that on a highly
distributed logistics network so we
created the single box which is now
called Bosh post that took almost two
and a half years to correct and in the
process
USPS almost wanted to put me in jail
because we had hacked their entire
shipping system not hacked it in a way
in a bad way but really created a
service that they didn't support and it
took a lot of negotiation meetings all
the way to the top to really create in
2014 what is now called Bosh post which
is a unique shipping system that allows
you to drop any number of fashion items
in a box put our label ship everything
one two today priority and as a seller
stylist you never have to pay a penny
everything is priced in and in fact the
pricing of that box which we launched
in June of 2012 and at that time he
launched the box for seven bucks is
today 649 and in between the pricing of
Priority Mail and other systems has gone
up by between forty to sixty percent so
it was a belief he took to the market in
2012 where we were losing a lot of money
and today that's actually a profitable
box that we can scale and really deliver
to millions of our sell is stylish
shipping millions of packages out there
so you have to take a core belief and
really not give up if you want to keep
things simple keeping things simple is
as we know super hard we are really
bringing social and commerce together
and this is really the power so for
example one of the norms we challenged
is every marketplace is built on ratings
Poshmark for the first three years
actually had no ratings even even today
the ratings we have are actually kept
private to a seller stylist the only
thing that is published is a five-star
note that is left that we call a love
note and that's built on the fact that
at the point a woman is actually putting
her closet online not only is she wall
durable because every feedback hits her
personally she is also not confident
that what she's putting in makes any
sense to put in and then slowly she
starts to actually sell stuff and that
is amazing but then you get one bad
comment and you sort of feel like oh my
god you know is it something wrong with
me or my style or my products and so
that's why we really focused it from day
one on a very deep emotion that everyone
wants to feel which is to be feeling
this feeling of love and if you can do
that then there's a lot of longevity you
create in the system and that's the
social part of the platform the second
thing is in order to drive the platform
you have to constantly curate massive
amounts of inventory to create freshness
so a seller stylists are empowered to
not just curate their inventory but
other people's inventory we're the only
marketplace we're really to succeed you
have to actually pay forward you have to
give love to other people in order to
build your own brand in that least to
almost today 7 million items being
curated by our sellers tie lives on our
day by daily basis six months back was
three and a half million back items
being shared on a daily basis six months
back it was just a million items being
shared on our daily basis so that's a
metric we scale and that ultimately
drives the entire
nything platform and ultimately drives
liquidity as well as sales for every
seller stylist on the platform so the
key in all of this is to really always
think about who you are building this
product for at a very deep empathy level
and and ultimately fight for that person
and how do you do that you have to do
that by being in touch well I'm not a
woman so I can't really look at myself
and in fact there could be a flaw if I
just look at myself as a customer of one
so on a daily basis in fact for the
first six months I personally tried to
answer every single customer inquiry
that come in and today I'm sort of
solving dozens if not many many dozens
of custom in Queens that come in on a
daily basis on different channels so in
fact at this point what we have seven or
eight things I have to respond to some
on Facebook some on Instagram someone
email someone private messaging some
through Poshmark that you sort of are
constantly engaged with the system we've
done I think hundreds of events over the
last five years and I have probably
missed only two so far traveling across
the country so you always have to be
constantly in touch with the customer
that you're building the product for we
really empower our community to spread
the love and that is one of the ever
binding feature and love doesn't have to
be completely ethereal it is something
that actually drives the development of
their brand development of their
followers and ultimately allows them to
succeed and in the process they're
empowering other people to succeed and
other people's to succeed and that
creates a community but the community
powered by love which ultimately ends up
delivering success to each of these
sellers through their incomes through
their independence through money so to
do that you really have to build
something where everyone is accepting of
another person and in order to keep a
culture scalable you have to from day
one build a tenant where each person
really accepts another person and in a
community that is very very critical and
so one of the tenants we have in the
company is that in order to accept other
people you have to first start to accept
yourself and if I were to look at all of
you which is hard to do in this darkness
I'm sure all of you feel a little bit
weird inside in fact part of the reason
you're sitting here is because you feel
a little strange
by embracing that strangeness and that
weirdness you could actually accept
other people and that's one of the core
tenets of community and that was founded
in the very very early days of how we
started and that sort of how we start
and and and live everything and that
allows us to constantly scale the
business and bring in different points
of views and differing different point
of views within the company itself so
that scalability which starts from
logistics goes into payments goes into
how we think about community goes into
how we think about love goes into
scalability but the one thing I did not
talk about is money I'm gonna go and
talk about money from day one we created
a partnership with our sellers stylists
which was a 20/80 partnership they kept
80 percent the revenue we kept 20
percent of the revenue throughout the
five and a half's or six years that
we've been around people have attacked
that somebody wanted to offer ten eleven
three two three four five six all kinds
of numbers ultimately most of the
business is melted down because they had
to change those models either start to
tax the customer more or come up with
hidden taxes etc in the five years that
partnership has remained intact
we have never raised our fees in that
same time frame Amazon eBay many of the
marketplace have changed their fee
structures more than a dozen time and
came up with 12 to 15 other taxes for
the customers so that is a trust that
you create because you're thinking of
scalability in the future and take the
arrows today so that you don't have to
change your system out later and that
creates a foundation where you've really
empowered people created a trusted
partnership with them and you can
deliver innovation to them deliver ways
for them to expand their business that
ultimately creates a unification of
everyone and and what we believe is
something that's going to scale forever
regardless of how the landscape evolves
thank you very much and thank you for
your time
[Applause]
you